le long de ce développement de caserne
lorsque les petits commerçants laver la
tête ils apercevaient l'amoncellement
des marchandises par les glaces qui lui
rez-de-chaussée au second étage
ouvrez la maison en plein jour et chez
cube énorme ce colossal bazar leur
bouche et le ciel leur part et c'est
peut-être pour quelque chose dans le
froid donc ils grelottaient au fond de
leur comptoir glacé
partout on avait gagné de l'espace l'air
et la lumière entrer librement
c'était la cathédrale du commerce
moderne solide et légères fait pour un
peuple des clientes il professait que la
famille sans force quand on la réclame
qu'elle finit fatalement par alejo
brouilly
leur fraudeur pour appliquer nos plats
et éviter la corvée de vaisselle
une élue vélo feuille d'aluminium
ménages
le petit commerce traditionnel a survécu
à l'apparition des grands magasins
évoqué par zola il ya près d'un siècle
aujourd'hui le conflit est plus aiguë
que jamais et commerçants revendique la
semaine dernière c'était le mouvement de
fermeture des boutiques la grève des
petits commerces
faut fermer pour marquer quand même
mécontentement vis-à-vis de des pouvoirs
publics qui n'ont jamais rien fait et
qui ont toujours essayé d'écraser les
petits commerces sont la seule de ses
préférés des technocrates
c'est un mouvement complètement
indépendant absolument dépendant des
audioprothèses quels qu'ils soient
l'eire
et qu'est ce que vous reprochez aux
dirigeants professionnelle égale et on
peut reprocher aux îles rangs
professionnels
leur manque de combativité c'est à dire
qu'au prix de leur tranquillité ils ont
laissé faire les choses si vous préférez
c'est la légion d'honneur qu'ils
interceptent d'autres choses voilà c'est
ça hier c'était 15 cent mécontents qui
défilaient dans le quartier des halles
ce n'est pas fini d'autres
manifestations sont prévues pour le mois
d'avril
derrière ce tumulte c'est tout le
problème de la place de l'avenir du
commerce indépendant qui est posée
nous avons maintenant sinon le père
j'insiste beaucoup sur le fait que c'est
un ce mouvement est absolument
apolitique
nous n'avons jamais voulu mélanger les
problèmes de politique et les problèmes
syndicaux
c'est pas nous qui vont donner le
mauvais exemple c'est à dire l'exemple
de la pagaille au contraire le commerce
a besoin de tranquillité de calme et le
consommateur aussi bien entendu madame
s'il vous plaît qu'est ce que vous
pensez devant tous ses magasins fermés
aujourd'hui mais je suis un jeune mâle
demandé j'avais l'habitude je viens ce
temps là c'est toujours ouvert dès
aujourd'hui c'est fermé non je ne sais
quoi pas écoutez moi je comprends pas
parce que c'est nous qui sommes
les esclaves nous ne pouvons rien dans
leurs réclamations c'est pas nous qui
pouvons y faire quelque chose je pense
une chose que c'est toujours le
consommateur qui paye tout ça il ya une
augmentation sur le linge de position de
50 francs 60 francs par acto j'ai déjà
des choses énormes mais au départ on
augmente les verts tout de suite le sang
chaud qu'est ce que vous pensez des
boutiques fermées aujourd'hui musique
c'est normal non
c'est pourquoi parce que la vie est trop
dure on n'y arrive pas ce sont des gens
fort sympathiques
seulement ma foi tout bien prendre ni
les uns ni les autres ne sont très
malheureux de biens sociaux au monsieur
au monsieur oui alors pourquoi cette
manifestation bien 6 1 d'après les
on-dit d'après les journaux c'est pour
les impôts c'est pour les taxes c'est
pour naturellement mais les taxes et les
impôts qui c'est qui les payent c'est
vous c'est moi
aa allait bien bonne
ainsi que tout le monde le sait
maintenant à la suite de nos mouvements
de revendication nous avons un problème
numéro un c'est celui de la fiscalité
des travailleurs indépendants allez
allez
lorsqu'on estime qu'une petite
exploitation agricole n'est plus viable
économiquement parlant
on a offert aux agriculteurs des
indemnités viagère de départ aujourd'hui
à travers les problèmes économiques qui
sont posées au commerce
nous demandons pour ces gens là aussi un
peu plus d'humanité il nous demandons
aux pouvoirs publics de bien vouloir
regarder de plus près l'aspect social du
problème et comme les visions sont le
souci tout un chacun
aujourd'hui nous n'avons plus la
garantie de retrouver à la fin d'une
carrière à un âge où on a plus le
dynamisme pour ce pour retrouver une
situation un travail si nous n'avons
plus à ce moment-là ce capital à la fin
de notre carrière bas nous craignons
justement de nous retrouver après avoir
beaucoup travaillé son 107e cette
garantie
en réalité le vrai problème est celui de
l'adaptation du petit commerce au monde
moderne
la moitié des commerçants ont plus de 55
ans depuis 20 ans 12% des détaillants
indépendants ont disparu
actuellement le mouvement s'accélère en
1968 on aura noté plus de 5000
suppressions de commerce de détail
l'origine de cette crise c'est
l'urbanisation qui favorise des formes
modernes et concentré de distribution
dans les libre service les grands
magasins les supermarchés et aujourd'hui
les hypermarchés les petits commerçants
sont en quelque sorte des victimes du
progrès
vous trouvez que c'est avantageux
oui certains articles quand même il ya
des différences de style vous savez dans
n'importe quel magasin s'appelle ça
devant des amis qui vont assume a
d'autres qui vont à franprix alors y'a
10 centimes 20 centimes en centre il ya
des petits commerçants qui ceux qui se
plaignent un peu delà de la concu a
quitté nous sommes dans un ancien
commerçant dans un genre un peu
particulier la caillerie choulet une
grosse différence de prix ou pas du tout
en rue moi je dis que c'est bien fait
pour eux j'étais président de l'asean du
syndicat des commerçants
je relis faut absolument qu'on se
regroupe pour faire nos achats en commun
avoir des meilleurs prix et vendre à
trappes aux gens de trappes ne pas les
laisser aller chercher à versailles ton
pourrait leur fournir ici ça durait six
mois puis après ça chacun a tiré de son
côté étrange alors ils m'ont proposé de
recommencer angers et non mais j'avais
pris une fois maintenant moi je fais
partie d'un groupement d'achat je vous
en mousse cariat ph ou à leur voiture
est ce que faisait lui aussi ses
supermarchés qu'elle touche pas sans la
moustache ça me plaît cinq quartiers
kingston si vous avez des commerçants
hôtels ont fait confiance
qu'est ce qu'on vient toujours selon m
est ce que vous faites confiance à vos
commerçants oui mais je vais toujours
chez les mêmes commerçants riez vous
nous nous insurgeons contre le fait que
les patrons des grandes surfaces anonyme
semble actuellement lancé un slogan qui
est à peu près celui ci le prix est le
seul service auprès du consommateur
or nous ne sommes pas du tout d'accord
avec cette façon d'envisager le commerce
car au contraire nous nous estimons
qu'en plus du prix et ceci est très
important il faut apporter une âme et du
service aux clients d'être bien série
vient accueillez humainement pas comme
un robot alors quand à vos grandes
surfaces évidemment ça s'est pris le
programme problème de la concurrence
le co ne veut pas propre que le commerce
refuse à la concurrence au conseil sait
bien que c'est l'homme de la deûle du
commerce
mais alors il se passe quand ils se
trouvent dans des camps de concentration
de capitaux qui ne boit dyckmans et des
commerciaux je lui réponds pas très
loyaux à lensois yolanthe veillant
généreux mais tout de même n'est ce pas
cette vieille thèse je perds sur le pif
teintées joindre sur le bas de soie
évidemment le commerçant le boucher peut
pas faire ça va se rattraper sur le bas
de soie donc il faut apporter tout de
même valu rapports commerciaux
incertaine
plus certaine équité deuxièmement les
grandes les grandes surfaces et vivement
aux bénéficier d'un certain nombre
d'avantagés fiscaux et je peux davantage
de capitaux que le petit et moyen
commerce ne peut pas avoir créé ce
malaise et cette inquiétude d'avenir et
alors on constate maintenant que toute
manière un retournement dans l'esprit de
la population qui s'est certainement au
départ enthousiasmé pour ces grandes
surfaces et qui maintenant s'aperçoit
que tout de même son commerçant qui est
à sa porte qui connaît quelqu'un hommes
de métier est un homme qui doit jouer
son jeu de commerçants qui lui rend des
services et biens au fonds présente un
intérêt je pense que les grandes
surfaces par rapport aux commerçants
traditionnels implantée dans le centre
des villes bénéficient de plusieurs
avantages d'abord la place la place de
présentation de la marchandise et
surtout la place de stationnement pour
des centaines de voitures
deuxièmement les conditions d'achat
puisqu'elle elle achète sont organisés
en chaîne elle achète en grande quantité
dont qu'ils obtiennent des conditions
forcément meilleurs et troisièmement et
c'est là mon avis le point le plus
important
le personnel formé de façon rationnelle
et même dans certains cas scientifique
qui permet une productivité
très très supérieur aux petites surfaces
les certains commerçants se plaignent de
cette concurrence qu'il qualifie presque
de clauses illégales
non je ne pense pas que l'on puisse
faire une concurrence illégale parce que
le service des prix s'y opposerait
interviendra immédiatement on peut
remarquer d'ailleurs depuis quelques
années aussi bien à l'étranger que dans
certains dans certaines villes de france
que les petits commerçants qui sage
offrir à leur clientèle les services que
les grandes surfaces de par leur nature
ne peuvent plus offrir arrive à
prospérer
justement voisinage de ces grandes
surfaces vous avez fait une votre
reconversion quétier vous il ya quelques
années en épicier traditionnelle dans un
petit magasin de 60 m² dans une affaire
familiale
j'ai commencé à militer dans les milieux
patronaux j'étais le président de la
chambre syndicale des épiciers
détaillants de mon département
j'ai pris conscience et je me suis rendu
compte qu'il fallait évoluer et sortir
tout au moins pour cette nature
d'activité de l'entreprise de papa
et c'est ainsi qu'avec deux autres
collègues nous avons créé une petite
société entre indépendants et réaliser
des magasins d'un peu plus grande
surface de vente pour pouvoir me
défendre
en face de la concurrence des autres
formes de distribution je crois que
l'indépendance doit être aujourd'hui se
retrouver au sein d'une organisation qui
lui permettent sur un plan collectif de
trouver des solutions aux problèmes
multiples que l' isolement ne peut pas
arriver à résoudre
pensez vous que face à la concurrence
des grandes surfaces des grandes chaînes
le petit commerçant soit condamné ou
tout au moins en voie de déclin je ne
crois pas que le petit commerçant soit
condamné je pense qu'au contraire il y a
un avenir
bryant qui s'offrent pour le commerçant
indépendant pour celui qui veut réagir
pour celui qui veut évoluer qui veut
s'adapter
il ne peut pas le faire dans l'
isolement assurément je le répète il
faut qu'ils pour y parvenir
qu'ils se regroupent et au sein
d'organisations comme celle à laquelle
nous sommes rattachés
la réussite est toujours quasiment
certaine et pensez vous que si vous
n'aviez pas eu le soutien de ce
groupement
vous auriez fait ce que vous avez fait
certainement pas
on
les méthodes modernes de distribution
sont un phénomène économique
irréversible il n'est certes pas
question d'arrêter le progrès mais le
commerce indépendant ne l'est pas pour
autant condamné à disparaître
pour peu qu'ils acceptent d'évoluer
en